welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and let's talk about The Flash
movie in the very peculiar way it
approaches timeline logic I call this
the pasghetti theory because everyone in
this movie is eating poorly made
spaghetti and everyone's teeth are
falling out like toddlers but based on
the rules of how timelines work in this
Flash Film and how it contradicts our
understanding to movies like Avengers
endgame there may actually be an answer
to the big question left from this movie
who killed Barry's mother Nora Ellen
quick announcement here Marvel's secret
invasion is coming to Disney plus June
21st my Easter egg breakdown is coming
to the new Rockstar's main channel that
day around 3 pm Eastern and there are so
many details and conspiracy theories in
the show that you just gotta tune in and
we're gonna know you're a scroll also
our after show inside Marvel is coming
back to Wednesday mornings live in
person West Coast Avengers unite and it
will transition to being a break room
Channel exclusive so be sure to
subscribe to the break room as well as
our Deep dive channel for other great
content okay early in the flash Barry
Allen explains to Iris West the specific
timeline of events around his mother
Nora's murder and his father Henry being
falsely convicted of it Barry says my
dad wasn't even at home my mom sent him
to go get a can of tomatoes I thought
whoever broke into the house thought it
was empty my mom was in there with the
knife in her hand and things went bad
just an absurd chain of events absurd
indeed in The Flash comics we learned
Barry's mother was actually killed by
reverse flash eobard Thon a villain from
the future who named needs Barry Allen
to exists as the flash to lead to his
own existence and thus needed Barry's
inside an incident to become the flash
his mother's murder basically for eobard
the ends justify the means because the
means just defied the ends but the
character of reverse flash does not come
up at all in this film we're just left
with the lingering mystery of who would
have stabbed a woman to death in a
relatively safe neighborhood in broad
daylight with elderly neighbors going on
walks these robbers assume just because
the husband and father left for a quick
grocery run that no other wife or kid
would be in a large two-story house so
people of the YouTube jury I present to
you that someone did murder Nora Allen
and that wasn't a robbery gone awry that
she was targeted with the same type of
motive as her murder in the comics so
who was it eobard Thon reverse flash to
the hypothetical off-screen future that
this franchise may never show us or
someone else that we did see in this
film well to solve this we must examine
this film's alternate approach to
Multiverse Logic the paschetti theory as
I call it Michael Keaton Bruce Wayne
uses spaghetti to actually explain it
saying at some point you probably saw a
movie that told you that if you went
back and changed the past you'd create a
kind of Branch timeline right new
present new future well time doesn't
work like that that's not how time works
you go back and change the past you
create a fulcrum you put yourself on a
whole other strand of spaghetti new
future new past it's retro causal it
goes both ways really it goes in several
ways now Barry starts asking about an
ontological Paradox model but Bruce Cuts
him off saying what you did is you
changed the future and you changed the
past if a person is stupid enough to
mess with time what you eventually get
is a Multiverse some strands run almost
parallel there will be inevitable
intersections and others that are just
wildly Divergent so unlike the way time
travel is depicted in Avengers end game
and Back to the Future Part 2. in this
movie there are no Branch timelines in
which history up until the rupture point
was left unchanged but then unfolded
differently thereafter but rather a
skewing into a completely alternate
reality in which history had already
been playing out differently up until
that point this movie offers as an
example the Back to the Future films
actually which in the alternate timeline
starred Eric Stoltz as Marty McFly not
Michael J fox who in the normal timeline
and in our reality replaced Eric Stoltz
Midway through that movie's production
and this history would have happened in
the mid 80s before any of these fairies
would have been born by the way I did a
really in-depth analysis of Back to the
Future over on the Deep dive Channel and
if you want to support the Deep dive
Channel please grab one of our deep dive
exclusive merch designs like this Indie
I love you shirt at nerdright.shop I
have a lot of writing to do for these
videos it's not just the stuff I say
it's also communication with everybody
behind the scenes at new rockstars to
make everything work as smoothly as
possible grammarly go helps with that a
ton okay so you know grammarly but
grammarly now has a new product to
grammarly go grammar go provides
personalized generative AI communication
assistance that accelerates your
productivity and unlocks creativity and
empowers me to do my best possible work
you can customize your preferred style
of communication by clicking set voice
to personalize your tone and determine
how you want to sound if I want to
coordinate with a production company
about an upcoming video shoot while
sounding formal get witty and engaging I
can do that in just a few clicks if you
need inspiration say for how to decorate
a set you can input a prompt and
grammarly go will provide you with ideas
for whatever you need the best part
about grammarly go is that you can keep
tweaking your writing until you're
satisfied with it grammarly go is
basically your co-creator you'll be
amazed at what you can do with grammarly
go sign up at grammarly.com
rockstars06 to get 20 off grammarly
premium but anyway this movie then
defaults into what I refer to as my
recurring eight types of time travel
categories Type 4 this always happened
AKA predestination in which the initial
Act of time travel was Faded by Future
time travel Shenanigans an unexplained
phenomena that happened and early in the
movie are later revealed to just be
characters in the future messing with
themselves in the past so in Prisoner of
Azkaban that mysterious Patronus that
saves Harry from the Dementors he later
realized was cast by himself looping
back on this moment in Christopher
Nolan's Interstellar the ghostly hand
when they go through the Wormhole and
the creation of the wormhole in the
Tesseract construct itself are really
the doings of Matthew McConaughey and
future Advanced beans looping back on
the past two ducks in Terminator
of John Connor and
breakthroughs at cyberdyne caused by
Kyle Reese looping back in history to
protect Sarah Connor and the T800
following him leaving behind his
Advanced robotics to the past that
cyberdyne would discover and use to
build AI the movie tenant does this too
really most time travel movies do this
because it's kind of the best way to set
up a mystery and pay it off in this
dramatic catharsis this always happened
and Barry confirms this later when he
tells Bruce certain people certain
events certain strands of spaghetti
drawn to each other like magnets I've
read all about temporal paradoxes and
causal Loops but this is more than that
inevitable intersections are something
none of the theories could have
anticipated because how do you explain
that except for fate and this movie
reveals that that mysterious dark flash
that knocked Barry out of the Chrono
Bowl to collide with his past self 10
years prior was that same younger Berry
looping back through time endlessly
disfiguring his body as he tried to
avert The Faded deaths of Batman and
Supergirl and his mother a closed loop
this always happened but if that young
Berry AKA dark flash tried endlessly to
alter this history what Cosmic Force
stayed a step ahead of him to make sure
that the history happened that that
night went into Nora Allen every time
going back to the question of who killed
Nora Allen again and again and again and
again well Uber Thon remains a suspect
and I think will always be the case in
comics Canon but we just didn't see him
in this film however this film's goal
was to establish Barry's antagonist as
himself it's his own variant who becomes
dark Flash and there is an interesting
moment where after Barry regains his
powers in the Batcave he experiences a
nightmare with who we think is dark
flash who's been stalking him this whole
movie it's a monstrous gargoyle that
snarls at the camera revealing razer's
sharp teeth but when we meet dark flash
later he doesn't have teeth like that he
just looks a bit older and withered when
his mask crumbles away therefore there
must be an even monstrous flash waiting
somewhere in the future a flash who
needs history to unfold with Nora
Allen's death who would stay a step
ahead of that dark flash alternate Berry
because he knew what that dark flash
would try to do and I believe that
monstrous flash is our berry the movie's
main timeline Berry not buried now now
not yet because we do see his heart
breaking as he says goodbye to his
mother and lets her go but imagine a
hardened more Resolute Berry somewhere
in the distant future who understands
that the means must justify the ends and
what happens in the final shot of this
movie Barry's tooth falls out now yeah
it's a funny callback to his loose tooth
earlier but yes leaving room for new
Jagged teeth to grow in let me know what
you think about this Theory again please
subscribe to new Rockstar subscribe to
the Deep dive subscribe to the break
room support us by grabbing some merch
like this Indie I love you shirt at
nerdright.shop follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at avos follow me rockstars
And subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
thank you